what a magnificent
setting it's hard
when you drive in here not to think of
uh
circumstances president roosevelt faced
and how he overcame so much for so many
so good afternoon a few weeks ago
i spoke at gettysburg about the need to
unite our nation
and today i'm here at warm springs
because i want to talk about
how we're going to heal our nation over
these past few months
there's been so much pain and so much
suffering
and so much loss in america
over 225 000 people
have lost their lives to a virus
many of those lives lost in the cruelest
way
possible alone
alone alone in a hospital room
alone in a nursing home no family
no friends no loved ones beside them in
those final moments
it haunts so many of the surviving
families
families who were never given a chance
to say goodbye
i and many of you know what loss feels
like
when you lose someone you love you feel
that deep black hole opening up in your
chest and you feel like you're being
swallowed into it
the tragic truth of our time is that
covet
has left a deep and lasting wound in
this country
millions of americans have lost their
jobs
and we see the empty storefronts in the
shuttered businesses
the visible signs of lost hopes and
broken dreams
but what we don't see isn't all those
parents staring at the ceiling late at
night wondering
how am i going to pay the mortgage how
am i going to pay
for my our rent what are they going to
do
if one of my kids gets sick now that
i've lost
my health insurance growing up
like many of you i watched my father
struggle to find work
he made what i call the longest walk any
parent can make
up a short flight of stairs to his
children's bedroom
to tell a child you can't play in that
little league team anymore
you can't go back to the same school
we can't stay here joey we can't stay in
scranton anymore
we have to move they're good jobs in
delaware
when i get one i'll come back
for you your sister your brother and
your mom
it's only 157 miles away joey
my father came home every weekend for
that year or more
but he always said when we finally got
settled in delaware
he used to say joey had jobs and all my
friends would hear it as well a job's
about a lot more
than a paycheck my sister heard it as
well
valerie he said it's about your dignity
a job it's about respect it's about your
place in the community
and right now in this autumn afternoon
millions of americans all across this
country
feel they've lost all that
a season of protest has broken out all
across the nation
some of it is just senseless burning and
looting and violence that can't be
tolerated it won't
but much of it is a cry for justice
from a community that's long had a knee
of injustice on their neck
the names of george floyd brianna taylor
jacob blake
they'll not soon be forgotten not by me
not by us and not by this country
they're going to inspire a new wave of
justice in america
these are historic painful crises
the insidious virus the economic anguish
the systematic discrimination and one of
them could have rocked the nation any
one of them
yet we've been hit by all three at once
but if we're honest with ourselves
the pain striking at the heart of our
country
goes back months not months but years
our politics for too long been mean and
bitter and divisive and you can hear it
now
in the distance we've stopped seeing
dignity in one another
we've stopped showing each other respect
too many among us spend more time
shouting than listening
more time fighting than working together
more time demonizing and denigrating
others than lifting them up
the divisions in our nation are getting
wider
angry people upset
anger and suspicion are growing
and our wounds are getting deeper
it may and many wonder
has it gone too far have we passed the
point of no return
has the heart of this nation turned to
stone
i don't think so i refuse to believe it
i know this country i know our people
and i know we can unite and heal this
nation
warm springs is a good place to talk
about hope and healing
sir franklin roosevelt came quote to use
the therapeutic waters
to rebuild himself stricken by polio
the polio virus in 1921
he suffered from paralysis like many
other americans of those pre-vaccine
decades
fdr longed to live an independent life
a life that wasn't defined by his
illness
to him and to so many others facing
physical challenges
warm springs offered therapy for the
body
and i might add and the soul but it
offered something else as well
fdr came looking for a cure
but it was the lessons he learned here
that he used to
lift a nation humility
empathy courage
optimism this place represented a way
forward
a way of restoration of resilience of
healing
in the years that followed fdr would
come back to warm springs often
to think about how to heal the nation
and the world
and that's exactly what he did
lifting us out of a great depression
defeating tyranny
saving democracy then it was here
on april 12 1945
that president roosevelt died a casualty
of war
as surely as any who fell in combat
and the free world mourned american
leaders wept
maybe even more important was the
reaction to the american people
naval chief petty officer graham jackson
the black man
cried as he played his accordion in
tribute to fdr
not far from here and the story's told
that when franklin dela rosa's funeral
procession went by
a man collapsed in grief
and the neighbor asked him did you know
the president
the response was no the man said
but he knew me
he knew me
a few words better describe the kind of
president
our nation needs right now president who
is
not in it for himself but for others a
president
who doesn't divide us but unites us
president who appeals not to the worst
in us but to the best
president who cares less about his tv
ratings
and more about the american people
president
looks not to settle scores but to find
solutions
present guided not by wistful thinking
but by science reason and fact
that's the kind of present i hope to be
i'm running as a proud democrat
well i will govern as an american
president
i'll work with democrats and republicans
my work is hard for those who don't
support me
as for those who do that's the job of a
president
a duty of care for everyone
this place warm springs
is a reminder that though broken each of
us can be healed
that as a people and a country
we can overcome this devastating virus
that we can heal a suffering world and
yes we can restore our soul
and save our country
in his last hours president roosevelt
was at work
on a speech to be delivered the next day
in it he was to say quote today
we must cultivate the science of human
relationships
the ability of all people of all kinds
to live together and work together
in the same world at peace
to live together and work together
that's how i see america that's how i
see the presidency
and that's how i see the future i tell
you this from my heart
i believe american and america of hope
not fear unity not division
love not hate the presidency though
is only one part of the american chorus
history isn't only a story of the great
and the famous no
our history is a story of we the people
of all of us together
i've long said the story of america is a
story of ordinary people
doing extraordinary things
change in our country comes when the
voices of the powerless
reach the ears of the powerful
when those whose names will never know
but who risked their lives
to in the words of dr king bend the ark
of the moral universe toward justice
bending that ark is the work of our time
but it'll take all of us red states
blue states republicans democrats
conservatives and liberals
and i believe from the bottom of my
heart we can do it
people ask me why are you so confident
joe
because we are the united states of
america
there's nothing nothing
the american people can't do and but
unable to do we put our minds to it
the news of franklin donald roosevelt's
death went out on the wires
an editor in chicago turned to his
college and said
clear the decks for action
so i say to you today if you give me the
honor of serving as your president
clear the decks for action for we
will act we will act on the first day of
my presidency to get covet under control
we'll act to pass my economic plan that
will finally reward work
not wealth in this country will act
to pass my healthcare plan to provide
affordable accessible healthcare
for every american and drug prices that
are dramatically lower
we'll act to pass the biden climate plan
meaning the challenges of a climate
crisis while creating
millions of good pain high pain
labor jobs we'll act to address systemic
racism in our country
we'll like to give working people a fair
shot again
in this country and will act to restore
our faith and democracy and our faith in
one another
today we're facing a public health
crisis of
historic proportions with winter at hand
it's getting worse just last friday
83 000 new cases in one day
saturday another 83
000 cases nearly 1 000 people a day are
dying
another 200 000 deaths are expected
over the next several months
and the president keeps telling us not
to worry
he keeps telling us we're turning the
corners his quote
it says remove from reality and as
offensive
as when he told us the virus affects
virtually nobody
just the elderly with heart conditions
virtually nobody just the elderly with
heart conditions
as if they don't matter
when he said in response to the number
of deaths
reaching a thousand he said it is what
it is
well it is what it is because he is who
he is
in the spring the president declared
in his voice as commander-in-chief says
commander-in-chief he was going to wage
war on the virus
instead he shrugged he swaggered
and he surrendered and then as chief of
staff
just last week made a stunning admission
an admission that i believe but never
thought he'd say
saying quote we're not going to control
the pandemic end of quote
we're not going to control the pandemic
it's a capitulation it's a waving of a
white flag it's a window into the
shocking truth
about this white house that they've
never really tried
think about all the front line health
professionals who've risked and some
given their lives
for the last nine months in this
pandemic think about all the first
responders
think about all the grocery store clerks
the drivers the delivery drivers the
trucks
teachers parents the kids home from
school
think about all those who've lost their
jobs think about all those who have been
infected by the virus
think about all those who've died
they were giving their all while the
president was giving up
well i'm here to tell you we can and we
will control this virus as president
i will never wave the white flag of
surrender just imagine where he'd be
today
if the president had embraced worried
masks
instead of mocking it imagine where we
today
with the president who practice social
distancing instead of holding super
spreader events
imagine word b with a comprehensive
system of
testing and tracing
i first put forward a detailed plan on
how to deal with this virus
back in march this administration
ignored it
then i released several more detailed
plans in the months that followed
the most recent just last week this
administration has yet to offer a
single plan
yes one of the reasons why the one of
the most prestigious
medical journals in the world the new
england journal of medicine called the
president
quote dangerously incompetent
went on to say president turned a crisis
into a tragedy i'm ready to act
i know what to do and starting on day
one of my presidency we will do it
i've talked about the battle for the
soul of america
since the very beginning of this
campaign and i want to be very clear
in these closing days about what i mean
and about what i intend to do in that
battle
to assure that our better angels prevail
over our worst instincts
i believe this election is about who we
are as a nation
what we believe and maybe most
importantly
who we want to be
it's about our essence it's about what
makes us americans
it's that fundamental time and again
throughout our history
we've seen charlatans the con men
the phony populist who sought to play on
our fears
appeal to our worst appetites and picket
the oldest scabs
we have for their own political gain
they appear when the nation's been hit
the hardest and we're at our most
vulnerable
never to solve anything but only to
benefit themselves
in a recent encyclical pope francis
warns us against this
phony populism that appeals to quote
the basest and most selfish instincts he
goes on to say
politics is something more noble than
posturing marketing
and media spin these so
nothing but division conflict
and oblique cynicism he said for those
who seek to lead we do well to ask
ourselves
why am i doing this why
what is my real aim
pope francis asked questions that anyone
who seeks to lead this great nation
should be able to answer
and my answer is this i run to unite
this nation
and to heal this nation i've said that
from the beginning
is badly necessary
the bible tells us there's a time to
break down
and a time to build up a time to heal
this is that time god in history have
called us to this moment
and to this mission with our voices and
our votes
we must free ourselves from the forces
of darkness
from the forces of division and the
forces of yesterday
from the forces that pull us apart hold
us down and hold us back
and if we do so we'll once more become
one nation under god indivisible
a nation united a nation strengthened
a nation healed that is my goal
that is why i'm running that is what we
must do
thank you all for being here and may
god bless america and may god protect
our troops
stay safe and wear your mask
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna give you my heart